[Música]
en otros temas la ONU advirtió que es
posible que el fenómeno del niño
comience este Verano del 2023 provocando
Un aumento de las temperaturas a nivel
global así como sequías y
precipitaciones en distintas regiones
del mundo incluso la Organización
meteorológica Mundial prevé que este
evento de origen climático pueda llevar
a Que las temperaturas alcancen nuevos
récords en los próximos años Cuál será
el impacto en América Latina pues se lo
preguntamos a gusto Quién es experto
regional en temas de cambio climático y
representante del penuma en Brasil
Muchísimas gracias a usted y quisiera
que empezáramos por el concepto en
general Por qué se produce el fenómeno
del niño y Qué tan seguido ocurre
Hola Muy buenos días Mira el niño es un
fenómeno meteorológico regular que
acontece pues cada cada dos décadas
durante un período aproximadamente de un
año
y lo que tiene que normalmente acontecer
en nuestra región es que debido al
aumento de la superficie de temperatura
de la superficie del agua sobre todo del
mar sobre todo en el Pacífico
ecuatoriano peruano esto causa una serie
de
impactos a nivel de mayor humedad mayor
presencia de calor sobre todo en la
parte de Sudamérica lo que lleva lluvias
intensas e inundaciones etcétera lo que
estamos viendo Es que debido al cambio
climático
los patrones del niño se pueden pueden
llegar a extremos no y pueden conducir
Pues a situaciones más graves de lo que
eran anteriormente Bueno en ese sentido
quisiera preguntarle Cuáles son los
países más propensos a sufrir estos
impactos del fenómeno y cuáles son esos
efectos que podrían producirse
Pues mira sobre todo en Suramérica lo
que se prevé es que tengamos lluvias
intensas con inundaciones con una
afectación en la agricultura en países
como por ejemplo México veríamos en la
parte pacífica pues una mayor propensión
a huracanes y pues en países como en
Brasil sobre todo en la zona del
nordeste brasileño Un aumento del calor
Pues un aumento también de
la sequía no con Pues el potencial
impacto en la en la pérdida no de
rendimiento agrícola pero también un
aumento de las temporadas de los fuegos
no y en países de nuestra región que son
pues muy dependientes de la generación
hidroeléctrica pues veríamos un declive
no en esa en esa cantidad de agua
acumulada en los embalses y por lo tanto
un declive en la producción
hidroeléctrica es importante revisar la
situación climática no Cada año los
países se comprometen a llevar a cabo
acciones para limitar el aumento de las
temperaturas y en esto llevamos ya un
tiempo pero qué tan probable es gustó
que este fenómeno del Niño no solamente
llegue a entorpecer estos intentos sino
que además provoque un nuevo repunte de
calentamiento global
Sí mira lo que todos los meteorólogos
parecen decir es que debido a estos
impactos extremos que vamos a ver en el
niño este año que tienen que ver con ya
el calor acumulado en el planeta debido
a la quema de los combustibles fósiles
pues vamos a llegar a temperaturas
récord en el planeta seguramente indican
los expertos que superaremos el
calentamiento de 1,5 grados que
acordémonos era de uno de los objetivos
del acuerdo de París sobre cambio
climático entonces debido a esta
acumulación pues este el niño nos va a
traer pues
esa superación de 1,5 grados
lo que estamos viendo Es pues una una
amplificación de estos extremos
climáticos y un panorama que va más allá
de América Latina porque se está
analizando Pues las potencialidades que
el niño pueda tener en aumento de
temperaturas y sequías en el cono sur de
África pero también en Europa y también
en el sureste asiático y finalmente
quisiera preguntarle por las lecciones
que nos puede traer el fenómeno del niño
pensando en experiencias pasadas para
poder mejorar la respuesta actual a lo
que se nos viene
una parte positiva es que en los últimos
años debido al esfuerzo de muchos países
y muchos organismos se ha aumentado la
preparación tanto de las agencias
meteorológicas como de las agencias
nacionales internacionales sobre el
riesgo de manera a poder predecir los
impactos del niño y poder preparar tanto
a las poblaciones Como por ejemplo el
sector agrícola y otros sectores no
Entonces esto es una buena noticia
tenemos más capacidades de preparación y
sistemas de alerta pero no podemos bajar
la preparación en esto tenemos que estar
muy atentos y sobre todo nos tenemos que
preparar ante un panorama global Pues
que con lo inestable que está la
geopolítica internacional Imagínate lo
que sería pues una nueva crisis agrícola
en el planeta debido al niño no
ni siquiera imaginarmelo Muchísimas
gracias es gusto manches experto
regional en temas de cambio climático
gracias por sus aportes para directo a
América un gusto Saludos a nuestros
televidentes quédense con nosotros
hacemos una pequeña pausa pero ya
volvemos con más
[Música]